bonjour fabrice epelboin merci de
répondre en direct à nos questions sur
arte france jacques toubon alerte donc
sur la neutralité des algorithmes
concrètement ça veut dire quoi
les jacques toubon met le doigt sur une
typologie d'algorithmes bien particulier
qui sont ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
l'intelligence artificielle ou le
diplôme ning et il faut bien comprendre
qu'on n'est pas du tout face à ce qu
habituellement on avait coutume
d'appeler un algorithme un algorithme
c'est un peu comme une usine en entrée
voulu donner de la data en sortie ça
vous donne une autre date à une date à
transformer dans la même façon qu'une
usine vous allez me donner du caoutchouc
et du métal et ça va vous donner des
voitures là le diplôme ning ça ne
fonctionne pas comme ça parce que si
votre voiture est un problème c'est que
clairement dans votre usine il ya
quelque chose qui va pas et du coup on
peut imaginer corrigé l'algorithme pour
corriger le problème qu'on a identifié à
la sortie d'une usine le diplôme ne
fonctionne pas du tout comme ça le
diplôme ning c'est un algorithme qui a
observé une quantité faramineuse de
données et qui va commencer à repérer
des choses et anticiper ce que pourrait
donner l'évolution de ses recettes de
données ça va vous donner c'est pas aux
abois qui sont capables de vous prédire
ce qui va se passer ou de vous de
prédire puisque vous allez aimer ce
genre d'abord il se base sur une
observation
donc si en sortie on a un problème une
discrimination typiquement c'est plutôt
à chercher du côté des données observées
que de l'algorithme lui-même et l'idée
de pouvoir corriger le dip learning pour
un tel problème est très compliqué le
problème la problématique réside
essentiellement dans les données
observées donc juridiquement c'est très
compliqué à appréhender pour une
politique qui a déjà une notion assez
floue de ce que c'est qu'un algorithme
et qui va allègrement confondre ces deux
typologies d'algorithmes qui n'ont
vraiment rien à voir il y en a à l'aider
à gori peu d'hier qui finalement sont
une extrapolation d'une formule que vous
pouvez faire grève dans l'excellent en
combinant des formules et en créant une
idée des données en entrée des données
en sortie ça ça peut se corriger le
diplôme ning ça peut pas saborder de
cette façon là évidemment j'aurais dit
mais concrètement en quoi ces
algorithmes de deep learning peuvent-ils
être dangereuse pour le
sue sociale et créent des
discriminations ces algorithmes de
diplômes ils sont partout autour de nous
pour le tissu social que vous parler de
quelque chose qu'on utilise tout ce qui
est facebook facebook a un impact sur la
société qui est aujourd'hui totalement
indéniable et qui n'est plus digne et
par qui que ce soit le coeur de facebook
c'est sur un algorithme là encore
d'intelligence artificielle qui à partir
de ce que raconte vos amis des cages que
vous avez mais des groupes auxquels vous
appartenez va vous faire un mix et va
sélectionner les informations qui va
vous donner à vous il est personnalisé
en fonction de ce qui va vous faire
réagir et cet algorithme et optimiser de
façon à augmenter au maximum les revenus
de facebook
plus vous restez sur facebook plus
facebook gagne de l'argent et plus
l'algorithme va vous donner des contenus
qui sont susceptibles de vous faire
rester longtemps sur facebook il se
trouve que c'est très dur
conséquence les conséquences de cet
algorithme et sont très claires c'est la
polarisation de l'opinion publique
c'est tous ces flux de haine tout
simplement parce que l'algorithme a
repéré que ce type de contenus créés et
de la fidélisation pour ses utilisateurs
qui revenait sur facebook pour défendre
l'idée que tout ça crée de la
polarisation mais que malgré tout ça
crée aussi des revenus et on efface un
algorithme comme ça
la justice française d'un tôt ou tard
automatisée des décisions de justice
basée sur ces types d'algorithmes va
observer des décisions de justice s'il
ya déjà des discriminations dont les
décidé observé à les reproduire
qu'est-ce qui est pointé du doigt
exactement ce que c'est l'application
stop qu'ovide qui est dans le
collimateur du défenseur des droits qui
sera mis en place mardi midi
l'application sauf que 8 c'est un tout
autre problème l'application stop
qu'ovide au coeur du problème c'est un
problème politique pas technique on a
décidé de centraliser des données
là où partout ailleurs sur terre on a il
a été décidé de les décentraliser de
l'aîné c'est sur les téléphones de tout
un chacun ce qui était la seule garantie
qu'elle ne pourrait jamais être
rassemblé et utilisé à d'autres fins là
en france on a décidé de centraliser
dans un premier temps on s'opposera à
google et apple qui proposait des
méthodes d'administration et dans au nom
de la souveraineté numérique et puis
dans un second temps on s'est aperçu
mais une semaine plus tard qu'en réalité
toutes ces données étaient confiants
microsoft dans des conditions
d'attribution de marchés
reste à éclairer mais qui sont d'ores et
déjà plus que douteuse c'est pas la
première fois on a une telle affaire
avec microsoft
c'est la énième fois qu'on a une telle
affaire avec microsoft là ça concerne
nos données de santé nous donner de
santé une fois qu'elle sera observé par
ces fameuses algues au rythme du diplôme
elles nous permettront typiquement de
faire de la santé est prédictive de
d'anticiper des problèmes plutôt que de
guérir des maladies
sauf que pour ça il faut être maître de
ce fait doubler et dès le démarrage de
ce projet qui est vraiment le futur de
la santé publique en france dès le
démarrage de ce projet on voit qu'on a
un énorme problème est que toutes ces
données vont aller une fois de plus chez
microsoft
merci fabrice epelboin d'avoir répondu à
mes questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur à sciences po et spécialiste
des médias
saignant enseignants enseignants
enseignera sciences po merci beaucoup
dans moins de